where are you
where is our leader
where are you dwayne the rock johnson is
not impressed the 48 year old actor and
former wrestler hit up instagram on
wednesday night to share a pretty
intense message
aimed directly at president donald trump
as we continue to wait for that leader
to emerge i
would recommend to all of you
that we must become the leaders
we're looking for okay so he doesn't
exactly address trump by name but he
makes it pretty clear who he's talking
to when he started off his
eight-minute long video like this where
is our leader
at this time at this time when our
country
is down on its knees
begging pleading
hurt angry frustrated
in pain begging and pleading with its
arms out
just wanting to be heard of course
johnson is referring
to the ongoing protests against police
brutality
across the country following the death
of george floyd a 46 year old black man
who died after a police officer pressed
his knee into his neck
for more than eight minutes
the jumanji star also spoke out against
all lives matter
a phrase that has been used to
invalidate the black lives matter
movement
of course all lives matter but in this
moment right now this defining
pivotal explosive moment where where our
country is down
on its knees the floorboards of our
country are becoming unhinged
in this moment we must say the words
black lives matter the baller star went
on to call out the president for using
military force against protesters
there
is military force that has been deployed
on our own people
looters yes criminals absolutely
but our protesters who are begging and
pleading are protesters who are in pain
you know you would be surprised how
people in pain would respond
when you say to them i care about you
when you say to them i'm listening to
you johnson said he wants to see a
better
brighter future i am not the president
of the united states
but i am a man and i am a father who
cares so deeply about my family
about my children and the world that
they will live in
and he gave a shout out to the countries
all around the world who have come out
to protest
in solidarity with the u.s i want to
take a moment right now to thank
the world for standing up with us
in our fight for equality to normalize
equality i want to thank all these
countries around the world
incredible inspiring beautiful displays
of solidarity
we see you we thank you we love you
[Music]
you